اذا في تفاصيل ما تشهده الجبهات في غرب
السودان تجددت في مدينه النيال عاصمه
ولايه جنوب دارفور شبكات تزامنا مع موجات
فرار في المناطق القريبه من قياده الجيش
السوداني خاصه في حي من حي الوادي قوات
الدعم السريع تتمركز في الناحيه الشرقيه
لمدينه نيالا بينما يوجد الجيش داخل وحول
مقر قيادته في الناحيه الغربيه في مدينه
زالنجي عاصمه ولايه وسط دارفور واحدى
معاقل قبيله الفور تدور اشتباكات وتتحدث
قوات الدعم السريعا تصديها لهجوم من قوات
الجيش السوداني وقعت خلال الايام الماضيه
ايضا معارك طالت مدينه الجنينه عاصمه
ولايه غرب دارفور هذه المره وادت الى مقتل
واصابه العشرات ولجوء الالاف لدوله تشاد
المجاوره وتاثر بالمعارك المطار الوحيد
الموجود على مستوى الولايه
ومنذ اليوم الاول لاندلاع المعارك شهدت
مدينه الفاشر عاصمه ولايه شمال دارفور وهي
مدينه متنوعه الاثميات شهدت اشتباكات وسقط
بسببها قتلى وجرحى ورغم توصل لمكونات
سياسيه واهليه ومسلحه الى اتفاق لوقف
القتال في شمال دارفور فانه ظل هشا هذا
الاتفاق هذا وتستدعي جبهات المواجهه
المشتعله في غرب دارفور في غرب السودان
عفوا القاء نظره على ابرز القوه
والتشكيلات العسكريه الفاعله هناك بدايه
حركه العدل والمساواه يقودها وزير الماليه
حاليا جبريل ابراهيم ثم حركه جيش تحرير
السودان يقودها حاكم اقليم دار فور حاليا
من ناوي ثم حركه تجمع تحرير السودان
يقودها عضو المجلس السيادي حاليا الطاهر
حجر وكذلك حركه تحرير السودان المجلس
الانتقالي يقودها عضو مجلس السياده
بالسودان الهادي ادريس